the Washington Redskins mascot isn't too
offensive it's not offensive enough if
you talk to people half of them will
tell you that Native Americans are
offended by the Redskins mascot the
other half will tell you that they're
not and what I've realized is we're all
just guessing Native Americans are
basically human Bitcoin I believe they
exist but I never got my hands on one of
them
also if you know anything about sports
you want the Redskins to have a racist
mascot because this is a terrible team
so if there's any young kids thinking
about being racist let's take one look
at that win loss record and be like
never mind nearly racism is for losers
so if you really care about the Native
Americans you make all their mascots as
offensive as possible the
Washington Redskins they should be the
Washington white skinheads the Chicago
Blackhawk lives don't matter the
Portland Trail of Tears
now you remember you didn't think about
the trailer tears in fifth grade